[Music]
so Abbi yeah incredible news we got the
cemetery plot was totally worth it most
of all we are nowhere near the
Schwartz's
Mazel Tov so how do you ladies like my
car to timeshare me let me jeez that's
bother Bobby going in on it it's me it's
Carl ship shitless we knew that one day
at Cloney a Williamsburg could change
your life Hana
control yourself excuse me I'm on the
phone Lana I don't want you to eat sushi
in Fukushima the radiation levels are
off the tree it's all over the internet
which big dildo penetrates a man oh but
wouldn't that be more like a gay thing
so nice to see you guys my dad didn't
love me half as much as I love you guys
you know son real double jumbo capacity
washer/dryer cleaning 25 pounds E at
dirtiest dog at lightning speed
[Music]